after two weeks of recovering in a
hospital Bishop marmari Emmanuel
returned to Christ the Good Shepherd
Church in
[Music]
[Applause]
Australia the bishop had some strong
words for the young Jihadi who stabbed
him repeatedly with a
knife this young man who did this
act almost two weeks
ago I say to you my dear you are my
son and you will always be my
son strong
words I will always pray for you I'll
always wish you nothing but the best I
pray that my Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ of Nazareth
to Enlighten your heart Enlighten your
soul your entire being very strong
words there is only one God Who Art in
Heaven the creator of all mankind and
everything else that is visible and
invisible and I say with absolute love
confidence and humility that God is
Jesus Christ of Nazareth some of the
strongest words you've ever heard
I'll always pray for you and for whoever
was behind this
act in the name of my Jesus I forgive
you I love you and I will always pray
for you if The Bishop's words were in a
strongman competition they would crush
Eddie Hall and Brian Shaw and the
mountain combined That's How Strong
these words are Bishop marari may have
lost an eye but his spirit is totally
intact of course when news of the attack
broke two weeks ago many people rushed
to Twitter to
blame the Jews Andrew Tate for instance
along with many of his followers the
tater tots insisted that Bishop marari
was stabbed for being an anti-zionist
preacher two problems with that theory
First bishop marari isn't anti-zionist
he just wants the fighting to end and he
says that he loves both Muslims and Jews
and wants everyone to become Christians
second the attacker turned out to be a
young Muslim which is why top G soon
deleted his tweet the Tater may have
made another embarrassingly stupid claim
but not to worry he can always blame the
Matrix what most people don't know yet
because the news just came out today is
that the attack on Bishop marari
Emmanuel ended up preventing a larger
more coordinated attack against Jews
when police investigated the attack on
Bishop marmari they uncovered another
plot involving some of the attackers
friends the Associated Press reports
four teenagers plotted to buy guns and
attack Jewish people days after a bishop
was stabbed in a Sydney Church according
to police documents cited in New reports
on Monday five teens aged 14 to 17 were
charged in a Sydney court on Thursday
last week with a range of offenses
including conspiring to engage in or
planning a terrorist act police alleged
they all adhered to a religiously
motivated violent extremist
ideology I wonder what that ideology is
sadly the Associated Press never
mentions the Rel religion of the
teenagers involved in this plot we can
only conclude that all the teens are
Mormons police alleged they all adhered
to a religiously motivated violent
extremist mystery ideology that can't be
named and were part of a network that
included a 16-year-old boy charged with
stabbing ayrian Orthodox Bishop marari
Emmanuel on April 15th as a church
service was being streamed online
according to a police fact sheet
tendered to the Sydney Children's Court
two of the defendants charged last week
discussed buying guns on April 19th the
same day The Bishop's alleged attacker
was charged News Corp Australia
newspapers
reported what were the guns for hunting
koalas poaching crocodiles let's find
out gun ownership is heavily restricted
in Australia under tough National laws
but there is a black market for firearms
in Sydney can't blame the authorities
for restricting guns since Australia as
everyone knows is entirely peopled with
criminals four of the boys charged last
week a 15-year-old a 16-year-old and two
17-year-olds allegedly used the
encrypted messaging app signal to plan
their attack I want to die and I want to
kill I'm just excited is your plan to
get caught or die escape a 17-year-old
allegedly said on April 20th in a group
chat the 16-year-old allegedly responded
we're going to be planning for a while
we prefer to escape but whatever happens
it's the kader predetermination of Allah
the newspapers reported darn
Mormons the 15-year-old allegedly said
on signal on April 19th I really want to
Target the yahood meaning Jewish people
the 16-year-old allegedly said of the
church attacker I know the bloku done it
and he's my mate so a 16-year-old
attacked Bishop marari Emmanuel police
then searched the teens devices and
found the other teens who are plotting a
more organized attack against Jews
Bishop marari lost an eye but ended up
saving who knows how many Jews On a
related note have you noticed how many
Muslim teenagers are getting caught
plotting terrorist attacks I wonder if
it's connected to all the dawa guys
telling young Muslims that the concept
of martyrdom in Islam gives them an
advantage over the Jews for instance
here's Muhammad hijab speaking to a
crowd of young Muslims about
Jews but then the question
is if your belief is one which is
encourages preservation of life at all
costs and our religion is not that like
that and yes preservation of life is is
important but preservation of religion
is more important and there's a concept
of martydom then I would consider that
to be an advantage frankly people who
seek martyrdom have an advantage over
people who seek to preserve life then I
would consider that to be an advantage
frankly
because as Robert Green said the one
who's willing to commit suicide has the
initiative now I'm not saying commit
suicide anyone this how we got him here
no talking about suicide mission here
bro I'm just saying figuratively the one
who's willing to take it further calm
down he only means figurative suicide
and figurative
martyrdom unfortunately that's where the
footage abruptly cuts off I guess we'll
never know what Muhammad hijab went on
to say in his message to Jews which you
can watch on
YouTube who knows how many young Muslims
were encouraged by hijabs video to seek
figurative martyrdom against Jews in
order to show the Jews that Muslims are
willing to go further with their
figurative suicide
missions speaking of suicide missions
the government of Australia is willing
to go even further than the young
Muslims the Australian government is
committing cultural suicide on a scale
that's only surpassed by the West in
general but whatever else happens as
Australia seeks cultural
martyrdom one Bishop upset a young
Muslim so much that the young Muslim
became desperate and enraged and jumped
the gun and accidentally exposed the
plans of other young
Muslims saving countless Jew Jewish
lives I've never met Bishop marmari
Emmanuel but based on his videos I
suspect he'd gladly sacrifice an eye to
save the lives of some Jews or the lives
of some Christians or the lives of some
Muslims remember those young Muslims
were seeking
martyrdom by getting caught following
the failed attack on Bishop
marari their lives were saved
too love never
fails no it doesn't
[Music]